we had to show you this video it's
deeply disturbing i mean it was it was
sort of chills up the spine disturbing
there was a show up in quebec in french
canada hosted by a woman named julie
snyder and they brought on some kids to
talk about mandates and vaccines and
what should happen to people
and well just listen to vaccines
we truly don't insult those
vaccinations obligatory
all right i mean
you see what we've done to children
okay so i don't know everything about
those kids individually and i'm not
making it about those kids and let's not
have anyone dox those kids i know my
audience would do that kind of thing
but do you see what we have done to
children do you see what we've done to
society the adults cheering them on yes
yes call the police arrest them do you
see what they're doing to society there
was a couple things in there first off
this idea guys as children as experts is
so deeply dangerous one of the things
that this reminded me of actually was
after the parkland shooting you may
remember the parkland shooting of about
three years ago at parkland high school
here in florida my friend and and
colleague now kyle kashuv was one of the
students at parkland and if you remember
all of the kids well all of the kids
actually who became
anti-second amendment advocates they all
got on the covers of all the magazines
and they all went on all the tv shows
and they did their town halls on cnn
where they attacked dana losh and marco
rubio and everything else and they
constantly were propped up by the media
then kyle eventually as the one kid who
came out of it in a public sense as a
second amendment advocate he sort of
made a name for himself through more
conservative media let's say but this
idea that kids should be thought of as
experts is so insanely dangerous that's
not to dismiss anything that these kids
have lived through as their parents have
put them in masks they've as they've
been forced to inject themselves with
things it's not to dismiss anything that
the kids at parkland or any other
shooting went through but because you're
involved in shooting doesn't mean you're
an expert
in guns and gun safety and the
constitution and our god-given rights
etc etc so they bring these kids on they
say the most authoritarian crazy things
their brains are not yet developed how
old were those kids maybe seven
something like that like they don't have
all of the faculties to really think
through the issues oh oh oh if you do
the thing that the state doesn't want
you to do call the police yeah let's get
these people out of society
this is seriously
nazi youth type stuff i am sorry if that
offends you or bothers you but nazis
didn't just show up one day we all know
this they didn't just show up one day
and it wasn't like a society was
perfectly healthy one day and then this
hitler guy showed up and then it was
like everyone went bananas and was
calling the police on their neighbors
and being like yeah let's get those
people into the into the trains right
these things happen slowly uh you
remember that video i played of jordan
peterson talking about this that this is
how authoritarians move you just change
things every day little slower people
stop asking questions stop pushing back
and then there's people like don lemon
who don't want people to ask questions
don't want them to do their own research
etc etc
and now they have infected
infected the brains of children
so that children
want to call the police on people who
don't want to do the thing that they
want them to do do you think this is
dangerous stuff has this thing gotten
completely out of control and yet it is
pushed and i would recommend to my
friends i know we have a lot of viewers
in canada and i know canada is a mess
and i've got at least
three i think canadian friends well i
have a couple of canadian friends who've
already moved here to florida but i have
at least three other friends who are
considering it right now it's like it's
not going to get fixed there you guys
don't have states rights justin trudeau
is out of control your media is funded
by the government like it's bad news you
should get out you should get out and
find a better place to live because
they're telling you what the next
generation is going to think so if you
think this generation of moronic leaders
like justin trudeau
are bad
what do you think that kid what do you
think that seven-year-old kid is going
to be like in 20 years when he's 27
years old and he's angry and he's pissed
and the world was destroyed and he won't
even realize that it was it was the
ideas that he was fed that destroyed the
world and now he wants more power and he
realizes that he can use the police to
arrest people who do things that he
doesn't want them to do because that's
the power
that has been given over to the state i
think we've got a problem on our hand
get out of canada